hi I'm hito me and I'm akka hi my name
is Keenan oh hi my name is Aoi takea
today we're gonna try some drugstore
sushi my experience with jokes or sushi
to be honest I don't recall the last
time I had jokes or sushi but I'm
assuming last time I had it probably had
a few drinks or something right they
have but only when I'm drunk I think my
experience definitely during times of
desperation my friends got food
poisoning from it you know we'll see but
we're trying it for you guys
[Applause]
- Bob the rice looks knit nasty
to be honest like if this is surd I'd
like something I don't like a lower-end
Raja or whatever I would yeah I could
see this fish looks very kind of dry
maybe with a little email but erm
pleading those issues Pema oh yeah it
looks a little tired a little bit
visually I feel like it's not it's
selling us what it's telling us you know
I'm gonna start this guy because I feel
like this is a safe one right I am a
salmon girls I'm talk perfect I'm tuna
so all right I will try the same one
okay
it's very orange I wonder if it's
naturally this color or maybe it's tuna
it's just at this point in their tuna
I'm talking about
[Music]
nobody not as bad as it looks
it's not a bad like mine that beneath
this well I mean I told you this is this
is my first time like eating this sushi
when I'm sober it's not that bad
nothing about the rice though it's like
oh the race is chewy it's very but it's
cold the sushi is cold and one of the
worst things about the drugstore sushi
is when it gets warm oh yeah I'm not
sure if this was like I was in college
and I just needed to treat myself and
this is all I could do this is all right
let's go back I don't any so this is
some enjoyment but inside it's like
there's like spicy tuna well cucumber
avocado oh yeah the rice is really not
there's not doing it for me but it's got
a nice kick to it
am I done I feel like I just had it like
same one I don't really taste like saman
you can't taste a fish like I could
taste the umber yeah that's just like
tuna in tuna yeah the tuna ception
this is like same things on the inside
another cucumber tuna avocado
all right back and that's that
[Music]
punishment I like that I like this tuna
better than like the one that's just
like the Tino you know I think the spicy
tuna is the saving grace yeah yeah there
yeah it's color can I stick to would
fish no I don't know Gary
it looks the most personally it looks
the most not the one that I want to eat
you're like salmon or tuna is your
Mesabi under here yeah nope perfect
little square square meat this is I
don't know when I go to like a George
store you got shushing now I think the
ones that actually had like a fish on
top and then like the like a little bit
more of like tuna or whatever I think
has to go to I think by having that like
spicy mayo sauce and eel sauce it masks
everything else that doesn't have much
flavor it's definitely something you
would eat in secret or I would even
secret I wouldn't want anyone else to
know okay I feel like if it was cheap
enough I will get full after eating all
that so good if it okay but if it was in
Japan I'll be like oh that's four times
calls for desperate measures
I think this is like a quick easy bite
they can get other to explore so oh I'm
like really really hungry I don't know
if I'm gonna eat drug sushi a gay
[Music]